I'm delighted to be here as time has
gone on
so frequently the oldest person in the
room there was in fact yesterday a rumor
going around that I had served at the
Last Supper I want you to know that's
not true
actually my career began in service to
Ramses the second favor or evening as as
you may know I had served as the
founding president of the National
Commission on certification of
physicians assistants I will really one
anecdote there's an error in at least
one of the textbooks that talks about
the history the Commission was actually
founded on August 8 1974 which is
enshrined in history books not because
of the Commission but because that was
the day that Richard Nixon resigned the
presidency and as we assembled that
morning knowing that he was going to
address the nation that night we were in
a hurry but we did have one piece of
business to transact and that was what
were we going to call these people who
were being certified as physicians
assistants CPA didn't seem reasonable
and so we quickly decided that we would
do PA - see five months later we had
identified Dave Glazer to be the first
executive director of the Commission and
he had opened his office in Atlanta and
on the first or second day that he was
there he received telephone call from
the executive director of the Certified
Public Accountants in this country very
curious after a little chitchat about
what are you going to call these people
and Dave said well we've already made
that determination they're gonna be
called PA - see and he said thank God
now all I have to worry about of the
cotton producers of America
the establishment and the growth and
development of the physician assistant
concept evolved from a number of factors
but principally from the perceived
shortage of health manpower specifically
physicians through the 1950s and 1960s
now whether there was a true shortage of
physicians is arguable what's not
arguable that positions available to
provide general care to the public was
in steep decline in 1943 of for
physicians identified themselves as
generalists twenty years later it was
only one in three while the ratio the
number of physicians of the general
population hadn't changed substantially
their distribution and practice profiles
had changed dramatically one factor was
the urbanization of physicians and the
population after World War Two which
deprived suburban and rural communities
of health manpower a second factor was
the explosive growth of medical
knowledge after World War two
particularly with the establishment of
the NIH in 1948 which led to an
exponential growth of information and
Technology physicians were increasingly
uncomfortable with the breadth of
knowledge that was necessary to practice
general medicine now while there had
been a few elite institutions that was
were devoted to the training of
specialists a major impetus was given
with Eugene Stead's arrival at Duke in
the mid
1940's dead is responsible for more
things than simply the creation of the
concept of the physician assistant when
he arrived from Emory he brought with
him a collection of men because most of
the faculty in those days were men who
later wound up populating many of the
academic institutions in this country
and instead suggested to them that they
might develop a departmental project and
what he had in mind was his blood logo
and as they thought about it they
divided it up Jim Warren later chairman
of Medicine at Ohio State took the heart
itself
John Hickam later chairman of medicine
at the University of Indiana took the
lung Jack Myers my mentor later chairman
at the University of Pittsburgh took the
GI tract and particularly the liver they
received grant funding from the National
Institutes of Health and began to
recruit residents out of the Duke au
staff to fellowships and the concept of
fellowships grew very rapidly with the
dissemination of much of the Duke
faculty throughout the rest of the
country and within a matter of a very
few years specialty fellowship became
the norm for training in internal
medicine by the mid sixties two
Commission's were sanctioned by the
American Medical Association to address
this problem and the consequences for
the public one of them was by John
Millis hmm who was president of Western
Reserve University charged with studying
Graduate Medical Education
that Commission evolved the concept and
the definition of primary care defined
it to include psychiatry office
orthopaedics office gynecology as
augmentations to the traditional
internal medicine or pediatric
residences the second was by dr. Willard
to study the educational preparation for
general practice they recommended a new
specialty of Family Medicine to replace
general practice with the Graduate
training curriculum and a new board of
family physicians to certify training in
this new specialty that was that report
in 1969 was very quickly responded to
with the creation of the American
Association of family practice out of
the American Association of general
practice and the creation of a new board
of family physicians 1966 the felony of
specialization was compounded by
Medicare and Medicaid that established
different reimbursement criteria for
procedures and time related services
such as the history and physical and
cemented forever the the trend toward
specialization in medicine the first
recorded public advocacy of a new kind
of health provider to fill the gap that
had occurred in physician manpower came
in 1961 when Charles Hudson who was then
president of the National Board of
Medical Examiner's spoke to the AMA
House of Delegates advocating providing
assistance to physicians whom he turned
externs now within the American Medical
Association that was surprisingly
well-received now Eugene stead knew all
about this in fact when he had been at
Emory prior to moving up to Duke
University
he was chair of Medicine during World
War two at a time when the number of
interns at the Grady Hospital declined
from 15 to zero and he then appointed
senior medical students to act instead
of interns and termed them externs the
same term that Hudson had used before
the AMA at the same time in North
Carolina there was a remarkable
physician and close friend of stead by
the name of Amos Johnson he was
exceedingly well known he served as one
of the first presidents of the American
Academy of Family Physicians and served
as president of the American Board of
Family Practice during its formative
years he had trained a guy by the name
of Buddy Treadwell to serve him as an
assistant and proclaimed to the rest of
the world that the only reason he could
participate in national activities to
the extent that he did was that Buddy
Treadwell was back there practicing
medicine handling his private practice
in his absence in the early sixties
instead having had many conversations
with Amos Johnson and working with a
nurse by the name of Selma Engels
developed a program at Duke University
to Train nurses to fill this role now he
should
known better because Hudson in his
address to the AMA had had suggested
that that was a possible solution but
expressed sincere skepticism that the
American Nurses Association would ever
go along with this and in the absence of
the AAA going along with it there was no
way it would ultimately work
particularly in the hospital setting and
had suggested that one might use trained
military corpsman who were increasingly
being produced as we were escalating our
small little altercation in Vietnam
predictably I think the program
developed developed by instead and
angles to trained nurses for this came
to an end when the National League for
nurses absolutely refused to accredit it
because these nurses had not been
trained by other nurses but had been
trained by physicians either in practice
or in residency and so instead took the
other option and turned to the folk who
were now coming out of the military and
they were increasing in number by the
year as our escalation in Vietnam
accelerated ultimately amounting to
seven thousand a year coming out of
Vietnam into the civilian population
with without any analogous occupation
and the civilian economy to employ them
a faculty committee was appointed at
Duke University under the chairmanship
of Andrew Wallace it was from Andy
Wallace that I learned about this
in 1966 the committee had deliberated
several members of the committee were in
fact ex-military and had worked with
Corman approval was given in the program
was begun in 1965 early in 1966 picking
up on this before the first class even
graduated Look magazine published an
article called more than a nurse and
less than a doctor which enraged all of
Nursing but attracted several hundred
applications for the second class to
enter Duke University as Andy was
telling me about this I had not thought
of it prior to 1966 there are a few
things in my life that had been so
instantly intuitive as the idea of a
trained assistant of the primary care
physician within those very first couple
of years there were competing models
certainly one of them was in Seattle
where dick Smith created the medics
concept again drawing on ex-military
corpsman more seasoned corpsman who had
been in in independent Duty corpsman for
a number of years at Alderson Broadus
concept arose of taking people out of
high school putting them into a college
curriculum giving them arts and sciences
as well as the medical training and they
emerged after four years leading to a
baccalaureate degree
John Kirkland at Alabama created the
surgical assistant and in Colorado we
had the pediatric assistant now
ultimately these had to be rationalized
but each managed to learn from the other
and ideas from each of these five models
enhanced the concept astoundingly the
concept was formally endorsed by the
American Medical Association House of
Delegates in 1969 I say astoundingly
American Medical Association may have
had another motivation for doing this
and that is the threat of what was being
projected as increased numbers of
medical graduates throughout the country
who might then compete with them in
practice nevertheless they did accept
the concept with an astonishing
resolution that encouraged legislators
and state medical boards to amend their
practice acts to sanction PA practice
the politics of this were were
extraordinary Estes repeatedly stated
that diagnosis and treatment were not
the role of the physician's assistant
that history-taking physical examination
and tasks ordered by the physician were
the goal of objective of physician
assistant training but he knew better
Duke was training him to do more than
that
but he never said so publicly and
instead was unbending on his insistence
on a dependent status and the political
statements coming out of Duke of course
were very effective in allowing the AMA
to make this public declaration in
support of the whole concept
worrisome to the AMA was the fact that
Carnegie had also already proposed the
expansion of medical education to
produce 50% more physicians by 1980 that
had to be terrified
the AMA action however was followed
within the year by formal endorsement by
the American College of Surgeons the
American Academy of Pediatrics and the
American Academy of Family Practice
which brings us to 1971
which was a highly significant year not
least of which because Yale started its
first physician assistant program under
the leadership of Fred and Blair Sadler
who were joined here by and bliss now
Fred and Blair as they will tell you a
little later
I had begun studying the idea of
physicians extenders when they were in
the executive offices of the National
Institute of Health the preceding year
had developed a preliminary paper in
1971 that emerged as a foundation
supported white paper that became the
book the physician assistant today and
tomorrow but in addition to the Yale PA
program and Fred and Blair and Anne's
book there were other things happening
in 1971 first of all in a quite
remarkable bipartisan effort the
Congress passed the comprehensive health
manpower training Act which did a number
of things it it intended to Moncrieff
physician supply by supplying money to
schools to create increased class size
money to develop new schools of medicine
in this country and money to reduce the
length of training
the length of medical education
decidedly ill-advised they were trying
to promote medical schools to go from
four years to three years by eliminating
summers and many medical schools did
that I don't know why anyone thought
that was a good idea you get a square
wave of one year of graduates and you're
done and then you're now compelled to
run all medical schools year round those
medical schools that did adopt that
concept reversed it was in the next few
years there now none of them attempt
anymore to graduate people in three
years but more importantly they provided
money to stimulate new types of
providers and explicitly physician's
assistants now there had been a few
schools largely Foundation and or
federally supported through one granting
agency or another that emulated the five
prototype programs at Duke Seattle
Colorado and Bureau of Health manpower
in 1972 provided money for 36 new PA
programs instantly quadrupling the
number of programs in one year meanwhile
the AMA took new actions their council
on medical education under the direction
of Bill ruie through its Advisory
Committee for allied health
professionals had developed a document
called essentials for an accredited
program for the assistant to the primary
care physician which was roundly
endorsed by the AMA House of Delegates
establishing the joint review committee
that ultimately morphed as we know it
today as arc PA at the same time they
authorized their council of health
manpower to major councils at the AMA
under the direction of Malcolm Todd to
work with others in the development of a
program of certification of physician
assistant graduates of now to be 45:46
programs that were in the pipeline at
the same time the national board of
medical examiners
appointed a committee on goals and
priorities to make recommendations to
their board for the future there's
nothing like being in the right place at
the right time I was asked to be a
member of that goals and priorities
committee and within six months we made
the recommendation to the board that
they undertake for the very first time
in their history the task of examining
professionals other than physicians
specifically the physician's assistant
that was adopted by the board in March
of 1972 and within 18 months the first
certifying examination was born what we
now have in the physician assistant
profession are the four key elements
legs of a chair on which of may a
profession sits if you will first of all
one of those legs is a professional
association the american academy of
physicians assistants have been created
at duke by the graduates of the first
two programs in 1968 with its first
president bill Stanhope in 1972 Duke had
been giving Invitational conferences for
each of four years and in 72 they
declared that was the last time they
were going to do that ladies and
gentlemen you take it from here and at
that last Duke conference in 72 there
was formed an association
the educational institutions that now
were in the process of turning out
physician's assistants and while he was
in the bathroom Fred Sadler was elected
president of the association of
physician assistant programs now we have
a professional association association
of educational programs under the AMA
auspice an accreditation system of those
programs and the final of link the final
leg of that chair is an accreditation or
a certification system in the public
interest in 1974 even though the first
examination has already been given by
the national board of medical examiners
with participation of specialty
societies state medical boards military
veterans other interested parties 14
national organizations came together to
create the national commission on
certification of physicians assistants
for which I was elected the president so
here we are today 40 years after the
most significant year in the history of
the physician assistant professional
development at both Yale and nationwide
I'll now turn this over to others who
will give you more details about how
this developed particularly here at Yale
and I thank you it's been a pleasure